une france de badminton aux allures de
cours particuliers pas de repos forcé
pour ces cinq collégiens leurs parents
sont soit médecins infirmiers ou aides
soignants
résultat leurs journées à commencer dès
8 heures par un peu de sport on a là un
petit peu la distance à
interpersonnelles qui est qui est là
donc c'est c'était le but donc ils sont
bien mieux puis ils sont bien les
pensées là maintenant ils vont aller
travailler choix céleste gaëtan paul
antoine et gabriel sont les seuls élèves
sur 1240 que compte ce collège à être
accueillis ici
après le sport place au travail encadré
au cdi certains aurait peut-être aimé
rester au moins un jour ou de ceux-là
chez eux
du côté des chefs d'établissement
c'était une évidence de pouvoir
accueillir rapidement ces jeunes
présents pour les jeunes et aussi pour
aider le personnel soignant qui puisse
aller au travail en étant serein
d'esprit vivre en sachant que les
enfants accompagnés hormis l'accueil de
ses élèves un peu particulier depuis
vendredi cet établissement de 3200
élèves fait face à la situation
prêt de matériel informatique conseil de
classe travaux dirigés
cette cellule de crise passe tout en
revue pour les plus grands et puis les
bac + 3 4 5
bien sûr qu'il faut qu'ils mènent leurs
projets bout ils ont ils n'ont pas le
pas le choix les entreprises
fonctionnent alors en respectant bien
sûr toutes les consignes de sécurité
et puis après pour les pour les plus
jeunes il faut assurer une continuité
pédagogique et les préparer avec la
supérieure mais c'est quand même une
phase d'apprentissage pour tout le monde
parce qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de
travailler à cette échelle-là
adaptabilité réactivité les maîtres mots
des établissements scolaires aujourd'hui
pour faire face à une situation
sanitaire toujours très évolutive